affront humiliation ou sexisme les
images de cet entretien avec le
président turc ont fait le tour d'europe
provoquant de vives réactions de cette
rencontre censée réchauffer les
relations bruxelles ankara on ne
retiendra que cette image celle de la
présidente de la commission européenne
interloqué réalisant qu'aucun fauteuil
n'a été prévu pour elle auprès du
président turc le président du conseil
charles michel et le président vicenza
hyper doan de leur côté prennent place
sans prêter attention à son émoi
ursula von der leyen n'a alors d'autre
choix que de prendre place sur le divan
en retrait des deux hommes au centre de
la scène
un incident vite baptisé sofa gate sur
les réseaux sociaux
beaucoup s'indignent de cet accueil
réservé par la turquie à la présidente
de la commission et de la passivité du
président du conseil
tout d'abord il se retire de la
convention d'istanbul et maintenant ils
laissent la présidente de la commission
européenne sans siège en visite
officielle honteux pathétique
y compris pour charles michel et non ce
n'était pas une coïncidence c'était
délibéré pourquoi le président du
conseil est il resté silencieux
les responsables turcs de leur côté
fustige des accusations jugées injustes
et renvoie bruxelles à sa responsabilité
dans cette rencontre
le protocole qui est impliquée lors de
la réunion qui s'est tenue dans le
bureau du président a répondu aux
demandes de l'ue le en d'autres termes
cette disposition des sièges a été faite
conformément aux suggestions de lui un
point c'est tout et bruxelles également
en ligne de mire se défend le conseil
européen organe représentant les états
membres rappelle que son président a la
préséance sur la commission dans le
protocole international
mais face aux critiques charles michel a
finalement tenu à s'expliquer en dépit
d'une volonté manifeste de bien faire
l'interprétation stricte par les
services turc des règles protocolaires a
produit une situation désolante le
traitement différencié voir diminuer de
la présidente de la commission
européenne les quelques images qui ont
été diffusées
on donnait l'impression que j'aurais été
insensible à cette situation
rien n'est plus éloigné ni de la réalité
ni de mes sentiments profonds ni enfin
des principes de respect qui me
paraissent essentiels
autre élément qui désole charles michel
le contenu de cette visite diplomatique
finalement occultée par cette polémique
pour un entretien qui visait à marquer
les profondes inquiétudes de l'union
européenne à l'encontre de la violation
des droits par ankara
ces remontrances seront finalement
balayé par un sofa